British actor Tom Ellis is having one
hell of a time playing the lead role in
TVs Lucifer a police procedural which
follows the devil himself as he retires
to the City of Angels and teams up with
LAPD detective Chloe Decker
so with Lucifer back on our screens
let's take a look at seven crazy facts
about the devilish show Tom Ellis may
play the former Lord of hell and Lucifer
but in real life he actually grew up in
a very religious family Ellis's father
was a Baptist pastor as his Ellis's
sister brother-in-law and uncle and when
they heard he was making this show they
were very excited for him
Ellis says he sees the show Lucifer as a
satirical story of redemption rather
than a big theological debate well
before the show had even aired it was
already the target of protests with
several organizations petitioning the
show's Network Fox to counsel a series
completely a petition on the American
family Association's website one Million
Moms which gathered 38,000 signatures
said the show mischaracterized and
glorified Satan and that if Fox went
ahead with their plans to Lucifer the
network would be disrespecting
Christianity and mocking the Bible this
isn't the first time the world of
Lucifer's caused controversy though or
the Neil Gaiman's Sandman graphic novel
which the TV show is loosely based on
along with the spin-off comic Lucifer
also drew fire from the American Family
Association back in 1991 not only is a
series inspired anti Lucifer protests
it's also inspired Pro Lucifer graffiti
yes in keeping with the show's devilish
spirit someone in LA or perhaps more
than one person took it upon themselves
to spray-paint the words watch Lucifer
on top of billboards advertising other
network shows such as NBC's shades of
blue and they even added a set of horns
to act as heads featuring on those
billboards including Jennifer Lopez Tom
Alice's steady doesn't know who did it
and he doesn't condone it but he does
find it very funny when author Neil
Gaiman created the character of Lucifer
and the Sandman graphic novels he was
inspired by David Bowie however after
reading the show scripts Tom Ellis saw
Lucifer as an Oscar Wilde or no coward
character with added rock-and-roll
spirit so he approached Lucifer as if
the character were the love child of
Noel Coward and Mick Jagger with a dash
of British actor terry-thomas the TV
shows still tips its hat to Bowie's
influence on the
books though by featuring his music as
for choosing Lucifer's accent
according to Ellis when he tries an
American accent the character came off
as a jerk but with an English accent he
found that Lucifer could get away with
saying all sorts of terrible things and
still come across as rather charming as
music is such a big part of the show
what with Lucifer running a nightclub
and singing and playing the piano
Ellis decided to make a special playlist
for his character which he listened to
during his downtime to help him get into
the part his playlist features a mix of
tracks that appear in the series such as
David Bowie's Fame and rebel rebel as
well as Ellis's own picks including
Purple Haze by Jimi Hendrix and Ring of
Fire by Johnny Cash
Lucifer's showrunner Joe Henderson has
even been known to listen to Alice's
playlist while writing scripts for the
show in fact Devil's hair cut by Beck
was actually on Alice's playlist before
it made it into the show's pilot episode
by the way Ellis comes from quite a
musical family himself his mother was a
music teacher his dad did amateur
operatic and all his siblings grew up
playing instruments with Ellis playing
trumpet and then French horn in
orchestras during his teenage years when
Tricia Helfer was cast as Lucifer's
mother Charlotte for the show's second
season Tom Ellis was blown away as not
only is he a massive Battlestar
Gallactica fan but he also used to have
a crush on the Canadian actress who
played number six in the award-winning
sci-fi series in fact although Helfer
plays Lucifer's mother in the show in
real life she's just four years older
than Ellis and she's actually five years
younger than DB Woodside who plays her
other on-screen son amenadiel Alice's
joke that it's all a bit weird and
oedipal and that he and DB both feel
like Stifler from the American Pie
movies while they were filming at Long
Beach for season one 7th episode wingman
the shoot was repeatedly interrupted by
a random drone flying around the cast
and crew
eventually the show security tracked
down the guy who was flying the drone
but he refused to stop so actor TV
Woodside marched down the beach to
confront the drone pilots who then tried
to make a speedy getaway in his car as
Woodside knocked on his door asking to
speak with him he was only later that
Woodside realized he'd been dressed in
his full amenadiel costume at the time
so guys what are you most enjoying about
the new season of Lucifer and what's
been your favorite part of the show
so far if you enjoyed this video do
comment like and hit that subscribe
button and before you head off you might
also like to watch my video with Tom
Ellis at Comic Con click here to check
that out and you can also click here for
my full movie and TV facts playlist with
more videos like this thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers